bienvenido a la presentación de la
integral indefinida o bien la anti
derivada vamos a empezar con un pequeño
repaso de la derivada entonces vamos a
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
de este aquí es el operador de derivar
vamos a encontrar la derivada de la
expresión x al cuadrado estoy aquí es
muy fácil si recordamos el módulo
anterior de derivadas hay que hacer una
cosa muy concreta verdad lo que hay que
hacer es tomar el exponente y bajarlo y
ponerlo como 2 multiplicarlo por el
coeficiente anterior ya que en este caso
es 1 entonces estos x 1 que es 2 y
multiplicar por x a un nuevo exponente y
cuál es el nuevo exponente pues es uno
menos que el exponente anterior
entonces nos queda 2x a la 1 que
simplemente es 2x eso estuvo muy fácil
verdad sigue igual x cuadrada entonces
sabremos que la pendiente en cada punto
de la curva es igual a 2x entonces qué
pasa si queremos hacer esta pregunta al
revés supongamos que queremos empezar
con 2x y queremos preguntarnos 2x es la
derivada de que 2x es la derivada
de que
bueno aquí la respuesta muy fácil porque
justo derivamos x cuadrada y obtuvimos 2
x pero pretendamos que no sabíamos eso y
entonces pues como le podemos hacer como
podemos encontrar una forma más o menos
sistemática de encontrar esta operación
como podemos digamos
derivar pero al revés entonces en este
caso la anotación que vamos a utilizar
plantación para 2x es la derivada de que
es la siguiente
déjame introducir déjame introducir una
nueva variable vamos a suponer que 2x es
la derivada de g
entonces 2x es la derivada de y vamos a
tachar este peque entonces os x es la
derivada de y entonces podemos escribir
que ya es igual y aquí voy a poner un
poquito de notación más o menos
sofisticada pero no te preocupes después
voy a explicar en algún otro vídeo por
qué se usa esta esta esta anotación pero
por el momento sólo hay que saber qué
significa la anotación o más bien qué es
lo que te pide hacer entonces voy a
dibujar y es igual a la integral
la integral de 2x de este símbolo de acá
que parece una víbora y este de x de acá
te lo voy a explicar después pero lo
único que hay que saber es que cuando
veas la serpiente y el dx y algo en
medio lo que te preguntan en el fondo es
que encuentres cuál es la anti derivada
de la expresión que queda en medio
voy a explicarte después por qué se
llama la integral indefinida y de hecho
cuando te explica cuando explica acerca
de la integral definida todo va a tener
mucho más sentido es pero bueno vamos a
suponer por el momento que ya sabemos
que esto aquí es encontrar la anti
derivada
sale entonces y es igual a la integral
de 2x b x y entonces ya sabemos cuánto
es porque ya habíamos hecho estantes
verdad entonces si es igual es igual a
equis cuadrada pero déjame hacerte una
pregunta que sólo puede ser x cuadrada
es decir la única función que al derivar
la nos queda 2x es x cuadrada pues x
cuadrada cumple pero qué tal x cuadrada
más uno que pasa cuando derivamos vamos
a derivar x cuadrada más uno pues ve la
derivada de x cuadrada es 12 x y la
derivada de uno es cero
entonces nos queda 2 x 0 y pues todavía
obtuvimos 2 x vemos similar cuál es la
derivada de x cuadrada más 2
pues si la derivada del cuadrado 2 es 2x
y la derivada de 12 0 entonces nos queda
12 x 0 entonces fíjate que la derivada
de x cuadrada más cualquier constante es
2x como lo hacemos para escribir esto
aquí en esta anotación pues vamos a
sumarle cualquier constante vamos a
poner una c mayúscula ojo hay muchos
profesores de cálculo que ponen más la
pregunta si se te olvida poner más c
entonces siempre hay que acordarnos de
poner más fe al final de nuestras
integrales ahora a lo mejor me puedes
decir bueno sal ya me contaste un poco
de la notación y ya me recordaste que la
derivada de cualquier constante cero
pero realmente todavía no me has
enseñado una técnica con la cual pueda
resolver integrales va pues vamos a
pasar a eso vamos a encontrar una forma
en la cual podamos integrar una
expresión polinomiales
a ver vamos a borrar vamos a borrar
vamos a poner todo otra vez en negro voy
a cambiar un color un poco más brillante
morado entonces vamos a
vamos a preguntarnos por qué si es igual
a la integral de pues vamos a poner una
expresión sencilla y polinomiales
digamos vamos a poner ya es igual a la
integral de x al cubo
dx
entonces lo que queremos encontrar es
alguna función cuya derivada sea x al
cubo
como le podemos hacer para encontrar
esto bueno con un poquito de intuición a
lo mejor piensas que tiene que ser algo
por x algo jeje bueno así está muy forma
muy muy informal pero déjame escribirlo
como ye igual a a
por equis a la n
entonces cuál es el valor de la derivada
de iu es decir que es de x
bueno pues una vez más ya sabemos cómo
hacerle para derivar esta expresión lo
que hacemos es tomar el exponente y
multiplicarlo por el coeficiente y luego
multiplicar por x a la n 1 porque el
exponente lo reducimos en 1 en esta
situación sabemos que aquí está el jugo
es de 7 x es decir es esta expresión
entonces déjame escribir aquí a la
derecha que esto es igual x al cubo y si
sabemos esta igualdad de expresiones
cuál es el valor de n y cuál es el valor
de a bueno pues fíjate que el valor de n
es fácil de encontrar porque n menos uno
es igual a 3
entonces n tiene que ser igual a 4
y ahora cuál es el valor de a pues ya
sabemos que apuren a por ende nos tiene
que dar el coeficiente de la derecha es
decir nos debe quedar igual a 1 aquí hay
un 1 ya que hay un 1 escondido verdad
entonces a por n nos debe quedar igual a
1 pero ya sabemos que en es igual a 4
entonces a debe ser igual a un cuarto
ahora simplemente usando recordando como
le hacíamos para derivar pudimos
encontrar cuál es el valor de g
voy a escribir aquí que es igual a un
cuarto de x a la cuarta
creo que aquí ya más o menos se puede
ver cómo que un patrón de cómo lo
hicimos verdad cómo pasamos de x al cubo
a un cuarto de quizá la cuarta pues lo
que pasó es que el exponente no
incrementamos en 1 y el nuevo exponente
lo bajamos lo pasamos dividiendo verdad
entonces vamos a ver si podemos ver una
fórmula más general entonces vamos a
encontrarla
a quien faltó un más si seguramente
hubiera reprobado este examen bueno
vamos a encontrar una regla general
vamos a encontrar la integral indefinida
de vamos a poner otra constante digamos
b por equis a la n de x
entonces que hay que hacer esto aquí es
un símbolo de la integral entonces la
regla que propongo es la siguiente que
el exponente de x lo incrementamos en 1
es decir hagamos x a la n azul y que
luego multiplicamos por 1 entre el nuevo
exponente es decir multiplicamos por el
inverso de n 11 entre n 1 y por supuesto
es sabe debe de quedarse por ahí alguna
voy a hacer una prueba más rigurosa de
por qué se ve pasa y digamos saliendo
del integral como si nada pero tiene
mucho que ver con cómo derivamos si te
acuerdas cuando derivamos también
podríamos sacar las constantes de la
derivada y no había ningún problema
entonces podríamos digamos como que es
sacar a derivar algunas cosas y luego
sacarlas de modo similar cuando
integramos podemos sacar la constante de
la integral porque simplemente integrar
es la operación inversa de derivar vamos
a hacer unos ejemplos
dejamos borrar creo que los ejemplos
ayudan muchísimo al menos en mi caso son
súper importantes para fijar las ideas
entonces vamos a encontrar la integral
de 5x a las 7 de ellas
a ver entonces lo que hacemos es tomar
el exponente e incrementarlo en uno nos
queda x a la 8 y luego hay que
multiplicar 5 por 1 entre el nuevo
exponente pues nos queda 5 octavos x a
la 8 y si no me crees puedes derivar
esta expresión vamos a tomar la derivada
la derivada con respecto a x de 5
octavos de x a la 8
entonces qué pasa el 8 hay que
multiplicarlo por 5 octavos nos queda 5
x ala hay que bajarle uno al exponente
es decir 8 menos 17 y hay aquí me está
faltando algo verdad aquí nos falta un
más nunca se nos tiene que olvidar eso
es siempre acuérdense va pues creo que
ya más o menos le vas agarrando la onda
a esto de integrar en los siguientes
vídeos veremos más ejemplos de
integrales de polinomios ya después
hablaremos de cómo invertir la regla de
la cadena y de cómo hacer integración
por partes hasta pronto